hi everybody I'm Liam Neeson and I am
NOT I'm Patrick Wilson and we are here
to do a wired auto-complete interview
yes I must say the whole Google thing to
me is ancient Arabic Google is Liam
Neeson is Liam Neeson British you're not
British - I am Irish no idea what this
is that has really stirred up some
problems okay
it's a retiree turning from what no we
don't retire you go interpreter is Liam
Neeson and Game of Thrones no I wish
these are really the first things that
come up came through it's fantastic is
Liam Neeson in a GMC commercial no what
are you the voice of not cars good cop
bad cop and the lego movie left him no
I'm not left haunted no he's got a good
right hook okay who is Patrick Wilson
that's what it's gonna be us who does
Patrick Wilson look like Chris Pratt and
will arnett that's not true I mean one
week I did go from Paul Newman in the
beginning of the week to Pat Boone by
Sunday it's true story haha who was
Patrick Wilson and ant-man that's a good
question because Patrick Wilson was not
in ant-man I was going to be in ant-man
that was Paul Newman that was Paul
Newman who Patrick Wilson Harry Potter
don't even know why would anybody search
me and Harry Potter were you in Harry
Potter no is there someone named Patrick
Wilson in Harry Potter who Patrick
Wilson killed that's fantastic today
know know anybody in movies I've met I
if I killed in movies I don't know
you've probably used so many people in
movies you've lost calendars what is
Liam Neeson famous lion and taken you
have a very specific set of skills I
don't remember a go on something so you
have a specific set of skills special
skills
something about skills very was
predicted see that later that personally
well I'm a Gemini so that means what are
you public I'm cancer
that means there's at least six of us
okay fantastic is the answer though it's
called the commuter starring Patrick and
myself
wasn't Liam Neeson's fading stable old
Irish street boxer can Patrick Wilson
really sing
yes he can yes he can my mother would be
so proud
um many musicals on Broadway can you do
my voice mail that's it Wilson you can
do it you can do it didn't know what
that means can Patrick Wilson look-alike
like what did Liam Neeson play in
starway and stop playing Star Wars plus
I was quite gone June why Gong Jin you
did win an Oscar for summers list no do
you as she did did Liam Neeson do a
Family Guy
yes I did did Liam Neeson was buzz play
you know that was very similar voice why
he did leave me some turned old on James
Bond my wife said she wouldn't marry me
if I did James Bond that's the truth
really but they were they were seeing
lots about directors - I wasn't the only
one
Patrick Wilson related to Owen Wilson I
am NOT it's very common last name I am
related to Mookie for you Mets fans -
Paul Newman I wish could be a son right
absolutely
no I'm not looks legend related to Will
Arnett's area go well I know it's a good
guy like well another range of Fanta
good hockey froy's a range of fun yes if
Liam Neeson had bad grammar but picked a
baby sir I'm sorry you cannot apply if
Lily's Narnia you're the voice of some
beast yes I'm a voice of Aslan the lion
right if you want money
I always won't want to hear whose need
money Liam Neeson was my dad you'd be
very protective yeah I guess
voice Nemo's dad no I didn't know
getting quite weird got dark very